welcome to our talk we talk about
building containers faster with ship
which is a container image builder we
built for job applications so who are we
we're a team based out of New York we
build tools for Java developers
targeting the cloud I'm a poo and I'm
cute
so cloud deployments nowadays are moving
from VMs to containers
many of you are probably already
familiar with containers which allow you
to say split your application into micro
services and orchestrate these was tools
such as kubernetes and Java developers
are already familiar with building jars
containers are sort of the same concept
daddy pine Java is very similar to the
idea behind containers which is this
idea of write once run anywhere however
building containers for Java
applications can be quite a confusing
and tricky process so let's go through
an example of a Java developer who's new
to containers and trying to figure out
how to write a docker file to build a
container all right so let's say I'm a
Java developer and I'm building a
website for a pet clinic
I want to containerize my back-end my
Java back-end and I want my container
image to be on my registry I love java
dot io / pet clinic app so what do i do
first i go and i search build java
docker image and i read the top few
tutorials and i'm able to write this
docker file so i run docker build but it
takes a very long time to actually do
the build so some of you have may have
already written a docker file like this
but to see what's going on here you're
choosing a base image you're installing
a bunch of things python software
properties some other stuff i don't
really understand
you have to install java 8 you have to
accept the oracle license then you run
and install maven you put your
applications on your container and then
you do your build on your container it's
a lot going on there might be a way to
simplify this and remove all the
unnecessary runs hmm ok so I read some
more tutorials and I'm able to write
this much better docker file I am using
a well maintained base image the open
JDK base image off of docker hub and I'm
doing as I copy my fat jar into my
container image and setting my entry
point to run that fat jar it's a lot
simpler a lot fewer layers so this is
nice it's very obvious what's going on
here I understand all the lines however
when I ran this build I saw that my
image was over 300 megabytes and I know
some people are concerned about disk
space so maybe there's a way to make
this smaller so okay so I do some
research I find that the open JDK base
image is 284 megabytes
by itself and that's huge making my
entire application over 300 megabytes so
I do some more searching and I find that
I can actually use the Alpine version of
open JDK Alpine is a tiny little which
by itself is only about 4 megabytes and
most only just using a JRE version so
this base image is only 82 megabytes
making my tarnish a lot smaller than
what I started with however it seems
that when I run the build it still takes
a while to do the build so it's not
obvious from here but when you do a
darker build the first step is sending
the context over the docker demon and
the context is everything you need to
make to build your container by default
the context is everything in the
directory with your docker file but here
you see we only need our pet clinic fat
jar so maybe there's a way we can limit
what we send hmm ok so I do some more
searching I find that there's a docker
file best practices and that's a lot of
best practices I see in there there's
something about a docker ignore file so
I do some research on doctrine or files
and I'm able to write this stock ignore
file ignores everything in my project
directory except for the fat chart that
I want to copy into my container image
so now my build runs a lot faster but
so I can outdo dr. push and have my
image beyond registry but it seems that
if I just change a single lime code my
push still takes a while why is that so
usually every line and your docker file
creates a new layer and your image is
made of a bunch of layers and our
example one of our layers is our whole
application so you change a tiny part of
application when you build you have to
create that layer again you have to send
it over if your application is pretty
large then that might take a while I
mean perhaps there's a way we can split
our application into smaller layers hmm
okay so I do some horse tutorials and
I've been able to write this better doc
file I split up my application to two
layers one for my dependency jars and
one for my classes files this way I only
change my classes files the only layer
that I need to resend why do a dogged
push is my classes layer and not my much
usually much larger layer with my
dependency jars so I think I'm good to
go all right
yeah except it looks like we still need
to run some maven goals to prepare for
our build you know that's the problem
with having to build files is you have
to maintain to build files maybe there's
the way we can do this in maven mmm okay
so I do some more searching and I find
that I there's actually maven plugins I
can use to define my docker build widths
in my maven pom.xml so I delete my four
lines of dock file at just 20 lines a
maven configuration it will do my entire
build from maven great I think I'm good
to go so there was a lot going on here
we wrote a docker file that we found on
the Internet we tried to reduce the
image size we tried to reduce how much
happened in the docker file we added a
docker ignore
we tried splitting our application up we
even tried this Spotify maven plug-in
which we're aware is deprecated but it's
great for this example there's other
things we didn't cover you have to
download install docker the order of
layers in your docker file kind of
determines your cache hits you can use
multistage builds there's more darker
cache things to be aware of and finally
you have to have your docker daemon
running as root
our colleague Ray has some more darker
tics tips and tricks if you're
interested it's not the point of our
talk but if you want to take a look it's
at this link here we're going to show
this link again at the end so when
container rising was stalker there's
many steps that exist between your
project and your container image
actually being on your registry you have
to build your jar you have to write your
docker file had to send that along
wizard jar via the darker client to the
darker daemon and then the darker demon
has to run a container or to build your
container image and then pushes that
container image to the registry but
we're all Java developers we don't want
to have to care about docker files the
containerization process should be as
simple as have your project running some
build and having your container image
just be on your registry so in our
example we have our pet clinic project
we run some build and we should just
have our container merge just be exist
on our registry so that's why we build
jib we built jib as plug-ins for maven
or Gradle so that you can containerize
your existing maven or Gradle projects
in two easy steps just apply the plug-in
and run the build so now I'll give you
guys a demo of how Jim works so we're
using the spring Peck net project which
is a sample project from the spring
frameworks projects and I'm gonna go so
right now I have to open up and we're
going to presentation modes you guys can
actually see so this is the pom.xml for
the sample of spring pet client project
go into the plugins I'm gonna apply the
trip plugin
I'll just set as a live template so
that's just going to apply the trip
plug-in scroll that bullet so this is
just applying plug-in I'm setting where
I want my image to be at once it's
containerized this is just a demo
project I've set up on google cloud and
I'm using Google container registry as
my registry so now I can go into my
terminal this directory was the product
I drew it just do it maven compile JIT
build and what this is gonna do it's
gonna runs through the normal
compilation for that spring framework
project and after that compilation
finishes it's gonna run the
containerization with JIT build so now
it's running
Jib build and it's building a container
image and once that that's done we'll be
able to grab the image reference which
is right here this is a image reference
that we set in our configuration and I'm
just gonna use docker to show you guys
that we can run this container so right
now I just I cleared everything in my
docker images already and I'm gonna do
docker run with that image reference and
I'm gonna just expose the port 8080 so
that we can hit it from a web browser
and see it in action so this is gonna
pull that image and run that image and
once this starts you can see our
application is starting up from within
the container we just containerized with
skipped colon build once that starts up
we'll be able to go to the web browser
and just hit the localhost 8080 and we
see our demo pet clinic application
startup from what's in the container
alright let's get the ice orientation so
in this demo so in this demo so we did a
jib build which is takes your job
application puts it and I container a
jhana registry but some of you still
have doctor infrastructure or maybe you
still want to try this with your
existing down yeah so we have one option
to build to a doctor demon you might
have running locally using for tests or
whatever and then we can even generate a
docker context with a docker file that
does the same build that we do in Jude
and you can use your docker build to
create an image in the example is all
default config but you can set JVM flags
you can choose your output image format
you can use OCI we have multiple ways to
set your credentials you need for
pulling and pushing to private
registries and there's an option to set
the program arguments that you
pass to your main so we want jib to feel
more like a compiler for containers if
you look at a docker file it kind of
feels like a script you know you choose
a base image you run a bunch of
arbitrary commands you can even run your
build inside your container for your
application and then you configure the
endpoint but a container Iser should
that's integrated into your build tool
should have enough information to do all
of that for you without having to go to
a second build so historically you know
codes been compiled into an executable
and a container Iser should take your
job application and just build it into a
container and java we've been doing this
for a while you take a joke you take
care of you take your application and
you jar it up into a jar and with jib
you take your application and you dip it
up into a container so let's let's go
into a little bit of how jib works so we
kept a few goals in mind when we were
developing chip first we want to have
jib be purely in Java so that you can
containerize your java project with
nothing but just your maven or Gradle
build systems we wanted jib to be
optimized for Java applications so that
you can deploy your changes fast and
incrementally and we wanted Jib to be
able to build images reproducibly so we
implemented jib completely in Java so
that you can build with just your maven
or Gradle build systems and the benefits
of these are that you don't need to
install docker or how to docker CLI you
don't need to run the docker demon you
don't need to have root in order to run
that demon and you're not actually
running a container or to build a
container so how do we achieve this well
first it helps to understand what a
container image is a container image is
just a directory of files and in the
docker image format this directory of
files is split up into layers each
represented as tar balls and these tar
balls composed into the actual file
system for the container and in this
format there's also a container
configuration including things such as
variables entry points
volume mounts exposed
portes things for when you're actually
running a container so this example of a
container configuration you have the
check sums for layers and in example
there's also entry point set which is a
command that's run when the container
images run and then in this format
there's also a manifest that just wraps
up all the components of the container
image your layers and your container
configuration this example of manifests
you have just IDs of the layers and the
configuration as well so also checksums
so in the drip image we build our
application layers on top of the
distillate slash Java base image this
chalice is a set of language focused
based images for languages such as Java
Python go and these images don't include
anything but just what is necessary to
run your application in that language so
compare this to alpine for example which
is a popular base image recommended by
docker alpine is still a Linux
distribution it's just a tiny Linux
distribution this relies on our hand
doesn't include package managers shells
or any other unnecessary programs but it
just was necessary so this helps to
improve security by reducing possible
attack services helps to keep your
container as minimal as possible this is
essentially what a container should be
it should be just your application and
its runtime dependencies so if you want
if you guys want to learn more about
this chalice our colleague matt has
great talk that's link to you in the
destroys repository so speed if we're
trying to replace your docker build we
want to be as fast or faster than what
you were previously getting so the way
builds work in docker is you create a
bunch of images say in this example you
have a hundred megabyte say base layer
and a 50 megabyte application when you
push it to a registry it sends both
layers over however when you make a
change it only sends a layer that's
changed so let's say we changed
something in our application and we do a
docker build and push this layer is
rebuilt and push the registry and even a
possibly better way to do is to split
your application even more
- let's say ear 49 and one and if we'd
done it correctly we're making all our
changes during development in this one
megabyte layer
so our sends are quick and they send
very little over the wire and Jib we
don't use a doctor file but this is what
we think an optimized docker my docker
file might look like for a job
application you see it's split into
dependencies resources and classes and
then we have an endpoint that ties it
all together but Jib doesn't use a
docker file it still builds like this so
here's a small example of like kind of
showing you how you get speed
improvements your first build using jib
or docker this docker is a docker file
example that we found on a spring
tutorial it uses a single layer for your
application opposed as opposed to three
layers like we do in jib and your first
build is the same you have to send
everything over to the registry if you
rebuild without changes they're both
pretty fast because they just have to go
through the motions of deciding
nothing's changed however when you
rebuild what changes to let's say just
your class files ship is only gonna
resend your classes layer whereas a
traditional docker build will send your
whole application over because that's
what you told it to do and here it's the
difference between five and say fifteen
seconds if you look it up if you look at
a much larger application down at the
bottom when you change this one might be
heavy on dependencies and resources so
when you change classes again joob is
only sending a small layer over while
Dockers or your traditional jogger build
is gonna send the whole thing over and
that in this case takes thirty five
seconds which is a lot of time to be
waiting for your build so another
benefit we get out of a custom image
builder like jib is the ability to build
images reproducibly so what does
reproducibility mean reproducibility
means that the same code always produces
the same image so for example if you
were to make a change and commit that to
say your get version control that commit
should produce the same image on your
machine as your teamates machine your
production machine
your CIC system and what this helps you
do is reduce Hospital variations that
cook her in a production container bill
that you can't reproduce in a local
development build so how do we achieve
reproducibility well we just wipe all
the meta data that could vary between
bills such as time stamps user IDs and
groups so now that we talked a little
bit about how chip works there's still
much more that we can do to improve the
containerization experience so this is
kind of what we're trying to hope we're
hoping to cover in our next versions of
jib we can have smarter inferences we
can try and figure out what port you
need to expose and do that for you where
there's other container optimizations
based on your java application like how
much memory you need or how much CPU you
might need we can try to organize your
layers logically based on what code we
think is going to change together so we
can hopefully have faster builds there
and then Java modules they let you
reduce the size of your JRE and we could
possibly reduce the size of your
container completely so we've covered
the build part but we're still trying to
get it we're still trying to make it
easier for Java developers to get their
code running on a container and our next
demo is it is an experimental plug and
we're working on to help during
development that'll get your jib built
image running and available for
debugging on kubernetes yeah so now I'll
give a demo of the experiments a plugin
we've been developing for be able to run
debug your chip build container on
kubernetes so just a little bit of
context Canaries is a tool for be able
to orchestrate your containers across a
cluster machines and here before demo we
already set up a community cluster on
Google Cooper days engine it's very easy
to do all you need to do is run that one
command
so we're had that setup we're gonna go
into our terminal and we're stop this
container from last step and so queue
control is the command-line interface
for interacting with your granny's
cluster can everyone see this in the
back it's good all right so it's going
to show they're just we have a
empty kubernetes cluster setup might
take a little while like every time
first time you run it might be fishing
credentials something in the meantime
so we're gonna go and apply it the
exponential plugin we've been developing
so if this is a live template as well so
I'm doing is I'm applying this plugin
without any configuration they'll be
able to just use the chips image so this
is called the kubernetes dev maven
plugin for now let's go back to terminal
so you can see the cluster is set up
with just kubernetes running so now what
we can do is we can take a project our
maven project and do
maven kubernetes dev and we'll do the
debug goal for being able to debug our
application I'm going to expose the port
8080 again and what this is going to do
is it's gonna generate the crew Barry's
manifests it's gonna run deploy those
manifest to the Canaries cluster and
it's running the application the
container in application with the
debugger agent library and exposing that
port and actually for that port to our
computer so that we can debug it in our
IDE so what we can do now is we can go
back to our IDE and go into might be a
little higher C but run edit
configurations and all we're going to do
is we're going to add a default remote
debugging configuration so add a default
remote and we're just gonna press ok and
now we can do is you can go to run and
just debug that configuration we just
made and now our IDs debugger is
connected to our application that's
running in our kubernetes cluster so see
the application is starting up and once
this starts up we can actually hit it
from our web browser but first let's see
what is in the cluster so as you can see
the panic application I start up as a
server
and the cluster and it's generated an
external IP that we can actually hit
live anyone can actually hit it in this
room so we can go there
alright let's first see if it's startup
it is startup okay
so let me make this bigger so let's go
see it's running on our kubernetes
cluster just like it's running locally
in our container so this is in a
container on communities so let's say we
wanna do some debugging
we want to let's say just don't show any
veterinarians so we can do is we can
perform a hoss [ __ ] so we can go back to
IDE and let's go to the controller for
that page the slash bets that HTML and
let's just comment out the line that
just adds all the veterinarian's to the
page we can save that go to build
recompile so there's a recap out of
class and it will ask us do the hotspot
so yeah
that's this reload class yes well reload
it and this will salt out the class
that's running on communities so now if
we go back to our page and refresh we'll
see that there's no batteries left
cool let's go back to France Asian all
right so that was a lot of stuff we just
did but what did what did we just do we
took our project we ran some maven
plugin a goal with a maven plugin and it
put it our application in containerized
form on kubernetes for us to be able to
bug and we were able to use our IDE to
attach to our running application and
debug our application that's running in
a remote cluster as if it was a locally
running application so so the tools we
built for helping you build stuff we're
working on to help your mind deploy
future now is we're trying to make jib
available as a library instead of just
plugins so if you're building your own
container builder tools you can use the
library underneath
and I have a lot of it taken care for
you we want to release the debug and run
plug-in possibly using scaffold
underneath if any of you familiar with
that that's another team at Google that
we work with and finally we know this is
hard but we want Java developers to be
able to run their job applications on a
container container cluster without
having to know anything about containers
so jib is now available in beta and you
can find it at our github repository and
welcome you to check it out tweet of
Ella's blog about us and leave us
feedback and we have quite a few minutes
for questions so let us know if you have
questions we're also probably at the
Google boosts not worse thanks a lot
[Applause]
no question yes so the question is how
do you integrate it to the main rule the
Raven a cycle of the life cycle right
yeah so uh so you can actually add it to
a face life cycle fades and just have it
execute so the plug-in you can find
executions for to say the build goal and
have it execute on the face that you
wanted to execute on as long as it
happens after compile I mean presumably
you would put it in package which is
where most builders or packages go and
we're kind of a packaging tool so yeah
and this is this is also available as a
Gradle plugin so in Grado it would be
you can set a dependency for the ship
tasks on whichever to other tasks you
want to run it after yes yes so
currently we don't have a way to the
five volume outs that you set that's
burned into the image but if you're
running the image on say Cabernets you
can define the volume bounds for the
other Kinnear yeah
yes yeah so he's asking if it's
configurable if you don't want to use
the base image it is realized this
realist is just the default we use
there's a an option to change where
you're pulling your base image from you
can use Alpine or whatever you want
sorry J frog yeah that's a your talked
about a job agent that you want to add
right sorry their container register Oh
continued registry so the container
registries it should support most like
cloud providers for teen registries you
can also even use a private registry
that you set up yourself so you can like
if for example you can even push it to a
local registry if you want so you can
run a local registry you can just have
it be like local host whatever port
software image so the first part of that
image reference is gonna be the registry
that you want to push it to so yeah
whichever other container registry that
you want to use it should be all it
would do it if it doesn't let us know
yeah we'll try to fix it it's not built
specifically for Google cloud registries
yeah or Google container registry but
you have to set up off
yeah yeah there might be some there may
be some credential issues with as your
came registry that we haven't figured
out yet but we're still working on that
all right all right cool thanks for
listening guys
[Applause]